russian missiles and air bombs hit our
country again from east to west
30 missiles for the lev region alone
the shelling of the international center
for peacekeeping and security
killed 35 people and wounded 134 others
nothing was happening there that could
threaten the territory of the russian
federation
and only 20 kilometers away on nato
borders
last year i had a clear warning
last year i made a clear warning to nato
leaders that if there were no tough
preventative sanctions against russia it
would start a war we were right
i've been saying for a long time that
nordstrom is a weapon that will hit you
now it's obvious
and now i repeat again
if you do not close our sky
it is only a matter of time before
russian missiles fall on your territory
nato territory on the homes of citizens
of nato countries
an american journalist was killed in the
kiev region today
his colleague was wounded it was a
deliberate attack by the russian
military
they knew what they were doing but not
everyone in the west seems to know what
they are doing
in the east of our country the invaders
decided to demilitarize and denarcify
the siviatriahus lover of the ukrainian
orthodox church
of refugees were on the territory of the
monastery
no military target in or near the
monastery but russian troops do not stop
even before striking at the monastery
this fact alone demonstrates that the
whole ideology of the russian state is
simply a lie
today i visited our guys our defenders
who are recovering from wounds at a
military hospital
we talked
i presented awards orders and medals
for courage for glory for ukraine
and i really want my greeting i wish you
good health to work today as powerfully
as our armed forces have been holding
key frontiers for 18 days already
by the way the russian military from
ryzen is being treated in the same
hospital
he's in the same ward with our defenders
gets the same aid
from the same doctors despite what the
guy was doing against us against ukraine
but ukrainian doctors saved him and this
is obvious
because they are people not savages
and we have to go through this war so
that we all remain human